if you're a property investor or
interested in property investment let me
show you something that's going to blow
your mind right now that house right
there that end house that rents out for
950 pounds per month
the middle house rents out for 875
pounds a month and then this one right
here see this one my house that rents
out for 4 000 pounds per
month
what's so special about that house how
is it different it's not different it's
pretty much identical it's just who i
choose to rent it out to let me show you
what i'm talking about come on so this
is a house right now which we just
bought i bought this myself along with
my brother i could rent this out just
the traditional way on an ast contract
when you rent the property out it's a
short short hold tenancy normally
they're gonna your tenants are gonna
stay for a minimum of six to twelve
months the tenants are gonna pay the
council tax get a removal van have to
pay a deposit you're in a long contract
i'd only rent this out for 800 quid a
month however this property instead of
renting as tenants we've chosen to rent
it out to guests because i rent this out
on short stay let's which means that you
can stay here for a minimum of two
nights and then you can go no deposit no
commitment i i rent this out for 130 to
250 pounds per night so on average this
property brings in
4 000 pounds a month instead of 850. now
of course we've got to pay cleaners and
we've got to pay you know expenses the
profit afterwards is probably two three
or even four times as much as it would
be so why would somebody pay 150 250
pounds a night or 4 000 pounds a month
to stay in this property why would they
not just pay
next door 850 pounds a month and the
answer is is convenience imagine you
only need somewhere for
a week or a month
you're not going to be able to rent a
normal house this is fully furnished
you've got your fridge freezer you've
got your wi-fi set up you've got your
cushions everything is completely ready
to go everything's set up normally when
you move house you've got to install the
wi-fi you've got to set up the council
tax this is like ready to go it's like a
microwave house it's just fast and
people want that convenience so that's
all the good i've given you all the
advantages of which there's a lot what's
the disadvantages well the disadvantages
is you need to actually run this as a
business and you need to have systems up
in place because hotels for example
hotels have got full-time cleaners
they've got a full-time receptionist
they've got staff
if you're setting up a property like
this you need to be able to systemize it
you need to have key safe outside you
need to have a cleaning company that can
help manage the diary
once you've set it up once you're good
you can then run all your properties
like this but initially getting that
system set up properly it does take a
little bit of time it does take a little
bit of work and it does take a little
bit of training and education in my
opinion so i'm going to show you
upstairs and i'm going to talk to you
about who the heck is paying 150 to 250
pounds a night to stay here let's go you
need to always keep it looking
absolutely great you know we literally
put all the little quirks and cushions
on them on the bed our competition
are the hotels and one of the ways that
we do market research on whether a
property is going to get fully booked up
or not is we look at the hotels in the
area and we see how booked up they are
and if they're fully booked up then we
know that we can rent a house out or an
apartment out in the area and we know
that our house will be fully booked up
because we advertise in the same way
that the hotels do we list this on
booking.com there's four types of guests
generally speaking that stay in
properties like this you've got builders
and contractors you've got business
professionals you've got tourists but in
this property 90 of bookings that we've
had on this property so far are
relocators that's people that are
wanting to
live in the property while they're
waiting for their house to go through
when i bought this property i knew that
relocators were going to be the popular
type of guest so we got this house
family friendly so
twin bed here so if you're like a family
of four or even maybe a family of five a
little baby with a cot room you're good
you can stay in this house and think
about it imagine if you are
buying a house it's very unlikely that
your house sells
on the same day that the new house
completes there's usually a few weeks
whereby you're technically homeless
because your house is just sold and
you're waiting for your house to
complete now you're not going to want to
go and rent a whole new house and have
to get wi-fi set up and get council tax
set up and get your utility bills and
get a removal van just for the sake of a
few weeks and you can't because ast
contracts are a minimum of six months so
what are you gonna do you're gonna stay
in a hotel
and have to book multiple hotel rooms
and you've got to keep your eye on your
kids and it's difficult you're gonna put
one big hotel room no
you're gonna stay in one of my houses
and you're gonna pay 150 to 250 pounds a
night which is the same you'd pay in a
hotel anyway but you've got your own
kitchen you've got a car parking space
you've got your privacy and often three
weeks turns into three months so i'm
happy
they're happy because they're getting
their flexibility rather than having to
move house and set everything up they're
not in a hotel and this is the way
of property investing in 2022
[Music]
you